E-Autos. Für die einen sind sie
viel, viel sicherer als Verbrenner,
für die anderen sind sie rollende Brandbomben, die
gefährlichen Sondermüll zurücklassen. Im Internet,
bei Familienfeiern und in der Mittagspause
wird immer wieder hitzig darüber diskutiert.
Wer hat recht? Das Thema wirkt auf den ersten
Blick vielleicht nicht unglaublich komplex,
aber glaubt uns: Das ist es. Wir haben bei
der Feuerwehr, einem Recyclingunternehmen
und bei diversen Behörden und Versicherungen
nachgefragt. Wir haben uns für euch die Finger
wund recherchiert und bringen euch in diesem
Doktor Whatson-Video kompakt alle Fakten. Wie
oft brennen E-Autos wirklich? Stellen sie
für die Feuerwehr wirklich so ein großes
Problem dar? Und welche falsche Zahl wird dazu
seit Jahren von allen möglichen Medien – sogar
der Tagesschau – immer wieder wiederholt?
Herzlich Willkommen bei Doktor Whatson.
[Intro]
#Wie oft brennen E-Autos?
Also: Wie oft brennen E-Autos? Am besten sollten
es ja die wissen, die die Schäden bezahlen:
Versicherungen. Aber falsch gedacht! Der
GDV konnte uns nur sagen: jährlich gibt
es in Deutschland ungefähr 40.000 Autobrände,
davon circa 25.000 kleinere Schmorbrände. Und es
gebe keinerlei Hinweise, dass E-Fahrzeuge häufiger
brennen – eine konkrete Statistik dazu ist noch im
Aufbau. Von einem großen Versicherungsunternehmen
bekamen wir immerhin die Info, dass E-Autos bei
Brand deutlich unterrepräsentiert seien, aber
immer noch keine Zahlen – egal wo wir suchen.
Außer eine, die überall im Internet zitiert wird:
Ein amerikanischer Versicherungsberater gibt an,
dass E-Autos um den Faktor 60 seltener brennen
als Verbrenner! Das klingt erstmal toll,
zumindest für E-Autos, aber damit gibt es gleich
mehrere Probleme. Wir wollten euch den Grundkurs
Statistik ersparen, darum findet ihr eine
ausgiebige Erklärung in den Kommentaren.
Hier kommt die Kurzfassung:
Erstens: Die Statistik rechnet
Verkaufszahlen aus einem Jahr hoch, statt auf
die Bestandsflotte zu schauen, also die Autos,
die gerade unterwegs sind. Das verzerrt
das Bild, vermutlich zugunsten der E-Autos,
weil ihr Anteil gerade stark steigt.
Zweitens: Die Herkunft der Daten ist unklar. Die
zitierte Behörde differenziert bei Fahrzeugbränden
nicht nach Antriebsart. Wir wollten also wissen,
ob die Zahlen einfach ausgedacht oder “nur”
schlecht zitiert sind. Und wir haben Grund zur
Annahme, dass die Verkaufsdaten aus 2018 stammen,
obwohl sie mit “2023 Findings” überschrieben sind!
Ihr seht: Die Seite aktualisiert einfach die
Überschrift auf das Kalenderjahr, aber man kann
natürlich nicht einfach alte Daten verbreiten,
während man behauptet, sie seien brandneu!
Ok. Was bedeutet das jetzt? Hier werden
fehlerhafte oder zumindest fragwürdige Statistiken
immer wieder aufgegriffen und verbreitet. Also
schauen wir mal woanders nach Zahlen. Und da sieht
es für E-Autos erstmal gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Teslas Fahrzeugdaten zeigen zum Beispiel, dass
Teslas pro gefahrenem Kilometer 11-mal seltener
brennen als das Durchschnittsfahrzeug in den USA.
Das sind aber natürlich die Herstellerdaten,
die immer einen Bias haben können.
Aber Skandinavien hat keinen Bias und da gibt es
heute schon einen hohen E-Auto-Anteil. Und nach
den Daten aus Schweden und Norwegen brennen
E-Autos und Hybride deutlich seltener. In
Schweden liegen die Werte der letzten 5 Jahre im
Bereich vom Faktor 8 bis 10 Mal seltener. Und in
Norwegen brannten E-Autos fünfmal seltener
und 2022 sogar fast siebenmal seltener. Auch
dazu haben wir euch unsere Recherchen im
angepinnten Kommentar zusammengefasst.
Und zu all diesen Daten muss man
fairerweise dazu sagen: E-Autos sind
natürlich tendenziell neuer. Welchen Einfluss
die Batteriealterung auf die Brandgefahr hat,
kann man leider noch nicht genau sagen.
Okeeeee… Was nehmen wir mit? Aus Deutschland
gibt es noch keine belastbaren Daten. Aber es
gibt gute Hinweise, zum Beispiel aus Skandinavien,
die zeigen, dass E-Autos bisher deutlich
seltener brennen. Und das bringt uns zu
der großen Frage: {Warum fangen Autos
eigentlich überhaupt an zu brennen}?
#Wieso brennt eine Batterie?
Tatsächlich ist der Grund für
einen Brand nämlich nur in seltenen Fällen direkt
ein Unfall, und bei Crashtests schneiden E-Autos
echt gut ab. Die genauen Ursachen werden
leider statistisch nicht erfasst. Das macht
es natürlich schwierig, das genau zu sagen.
Trotzdem wollen wir das jetzt mal versuchen.
Wenn wir über E-Auto-Brände sprechen, müssen
wir aber erstmal zwischen Fahrzeugbränden und
Batteriebränden unterscheiden. Denn letzteres,
also dass wirklich die Batterie des Autos brennt,
ist laut eines Experten viel seltener der Fall.
Aber für viele ist Batteriebrand ja synonym mit
E-Auto-Brand, und genau darum schauen wir uns
jetzt die Batteriebrände mal genauer an.
Wir wissen, dass eine Batterie leichter
brennt, je mehr sie geladen ist,
und dass es eine zusätzliche Belastung geben
muss, für die sie nicht ausgelegt ist.
Das kann thermisch – zum Beispiel durch ein
Feuer von außen –, elektrisch – Überladung
oder Tiefentladung –, oder mechanisch – zum
Beispiel durch Verbiegen – passieren. Aber
es gibt verschiedene Schutzmechanismen,
um einen Batteriebrand zu verhindern,
das Batterie-Management-System
zum Beispiel, oder das Gehäuse.
Wenn aber eines dieser Systeme versagt, kann
es zu einem sogenannten “thermal runaway” oder
“thermischen Durchgehen” kommen. Das ist ein
Phänomen, bei dem es im Inneren einer Zelle zu
einem unkontrollierbaren Temperaturanstieg
kommt. Die Batterie “gast aus” – sie gibt
potentiell brennbare, giftige Gase ab.
Und wenn es zu heiß wird, kann sich dieses
Gemisch entzünden, was wiederum die nächste
Zelle überhitzt. Dabei zersetzt sich die
Kathode und setzt Sauerstoff frei. Das
heißt, so ein Brand lässt sich nicht
ersticken! Kann man sowas überhaupt löschen?
#
Das haben wir Dr. Rolf Erbe von der Berliner
Feuerwehr gefragt. Er beschäftigt sich schon
seit Jahren mit E-Auto-Bränden.
<01:13:58 Rolf Erbe >: Brennende
Fahrzeuge werden von den Feuerwehren immer in
der gleichen Taktik gelöscht. Wir wissen in den
seltensten Fällen bei der Alarmierung, um was
für einen Antrieb es sich handelt. Daher gehen
wir erstmal grundsätzlich mit Wasser vor. Wenn
Flüssigkeiten brennen, dann müssen wir auch mit
Schaum vorgehen. Bei Elektrofahrzeugen
brauchen wir erstmal nur Wasser.
Wir müssen dann schauen, ist die Batterie
betroffen. In den seltensten Fällen brennt auch
die Batterie. Wenn das Fahrzeug dann gelöscht ist,
schauen wir uns die Batterie an.<01:14:20 /OT>
Okay, ein brennendes Auto ist erstmal
ein brennendes Auto und es macht für
die Feuerwehr keinen großen Unterschied. Aber
selbst wenn die Batterie brennt, wird mit Wasser
gelöscht. Das Wasser kann durch die Kühlung
den thermal runaway aufhalten. Oft heißt es,
dass man sehr viel Wasser braucht. Das liegt
daran, dass ja normalerweise einfach kein Wasser
in die Batterie kommen soll. Um den Batteriebrand
zu löschen, muss aber Wasser hinein.
Manchmal werden Autos deshalb geflutet.
Warum das oft nicht sinnvoll ist,
dazu kommen wir gleich. Man kann den
Wasserverbrauch aber deutlich reduzieren,
indem man das E-Auto auf die Seite kippt und
so gezielter an die Batterie herangeht.
Mmhhh – Hochvoltanlagen und Wasser… Viele haben
hier Angst vor einem elektrischen Schlag.
<01:17:25 Rolf Erbe> Ein elektrischer Schlag ist
fast ausgeschlossen. Wir haben kein geerdetes
System. Das heißt, wir müssen immer beide
Pole der Batterie irgendwie berühren oder
in Berührung kommen. Und wenn wir auch viel
Wasser darauf geben, der Strom nimmt den Weg
des geringsten Widerstandes, dann würde
ja der Strom durch das Wasser fließen
und nicht irgendwo durch die Menschen, was
eigentlich sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich ist.
Und auch eine Gefährdung für Ersthelfer ist
so gut wie ausgeschlossen.<01:17:55/OT>
Bei einem Unfall wird die Batterie übrigens
auch abgeschaltet. Und selbst für den Fall,
dass das nicht klappt, kann die Feuerwehr die
Verbindung manuell trennen. Gut. Was heißt
das jetzt insgesamt?
<01:07:54 Rolf Erbe>
Brennende Elektrofahrzeuge sind für die Feuerwehr
noch die Ausnahme. Sie brennen auch deutlich
seltener als herkömmliche Verbrenner,
und das sagen die ersten Statistiken.
Das heißt, es ist letztlich ein Brand
wie jeder andere auch, den wir löschen,
wir können löschen. Wir haben aber noch
keine Erfahrung, muss man sagen. Die
Feuerwehr lebt von Erfahrung, und wir müssen
das erstmal sammeln. Bisher jedenfalls gibt
es keine Erkenntnisse, dass brennende
Elektrofahrzeuge irgendwelche Probleme
für Feuerwehren darstellen. <01:08:26 /OT>
Okay, Feuerwehren können E-Autos löschen. Ein
elektrischer Schlag ist extrem unwahrscheinlich
und die Einsatzkräfte sind vorbereitet.
Aber über eine Gefahr beim Löschen haben wir
noch nicht gesprochen. Wenn ein Auto brennt,
werden giftige Stoffe freigesetzt, und
die sind danach in der Luft und im
Löschwasser. Und damit kommen
wir zum nächsten Punkt.
#
Fangen wir dafür mal direkt beim Brand an: Bei
E-Autos sind im Brandrauch mehr Fluorwasserstoff,
aus dem giftige Flusssäure entstehen kann, und
einige Metalle enthalten als beim Verbrenner. Aber
man muss sich bewusst machen, dass kein Autobrand
gut für die Umwelt ist, und dass Rauchgase immer
gefährlich sind. Um tatsächlich eine tödliche
Dosis Fluorwasserstoff aus dem Rauch über die
Haut aufzunehmen, müsste man selbst nackt 2
bis 14 Stunden lang im Rauch stehen. Und ich bin
zwar kein echter Doktor, aber bitte glaubt mir,
wenn ich sage, dass ich das nicht empfehle.
Nach dem Brand haben wir ein gelöschtes E-Auto,
von dem noch mehr oder weniger viel übrig ist.
Ein Entsorger holt das Wrack ab. Allerdings
kann sich die Batterie noch mehrere Tage nach dem
Brand wieder entzünden. Und um das zu verhindern,
werden die Autos manchmal vorsorglich versenkt und
stehen dann in einem Container beim Recycler.
Die DGUV empfiehlt das aber nur im Ausnahmefall,
weil der Aufwand einfach riesig ist. Das Wasser
muss von einem Entsorger abgeholt und teuer
aufbereitet werden. Laut dem Recyclingunternehmen,
mit dem wir für dieses Video gesprochen
haben, wurden in den letzten Jahren auch
schon unnötigerweise Autos geflutet, obwohl die
Batterie gar nicht die Gefahrenquelle war.
Und das führt uns zu einer Option, über
die wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben:
Kontrolliert abbrennen lassen.
<01:07:29,679 Rolf Erbe> Im Endeffekt
entstehen dann auch weniger Schadstoffe
durch die hohen Temperaturen, verbrennt
sehr viel. Und wenn wir wenig Wasser oder
auch gar kein Wasser einsetzen, dann haben
wir auch keine Kontaminationsgefahr, also dass
Verunreinigung in den Boden eindringen. </OT>
Und wie geht es weiter, wenn noch etwas von der
Batterie übrig ist? Bei den Recyclern werden die
Batteriezellen sortiert, auseinandergenommen
und recycelt. Dafür müssen die Werkstätten
Quarantäneplätze und Arbeitsplätze für Fahrzeuge
und Batterien einrichten und gegebenenfalls
Luftfiltersysteme installieren. Das kostet
natürlich alles Geld, ist aber an sich machbar.
Und da kommen wir zur Frage: Wieso denken dann
immer noch so viele Menschen, dass E-Autos super
häufig brennen, und was kann man dagegen tun?
#
Naja, Posts über brennende E-Autos sind zum Teil
auch einfach fake. Und E-Autos werden auch oft als
Brandursache vermutet, zum Beispiel im Fall
der Fremantle Highway, die über 3.700 Autos
geladen hatte, davon ca. 500 E-Autos. Dabei
ist die Brandursache bis heute unbekannt, und
die E-Autos sind alle scheinbar in gutem Zustand.
Wie sollen sie also den Brand ausgelöst haben?
Um E-Autos noch sicherer zu machen, gibt
es verschiedene Ideen. Zwei Akkutypen,
die deutlich weniger Risiko bergen, sind sogar
heute schon auf dem Markt: Natrium-Ionen- und
LFP-Zellen. Beide haben aber eine geringere
Energiedichte als die heute üblichen Batterien.
Eine weitere Idee ist eine Art Frühwarnsystem,
das die “Gesundheit” der einzelnen Zellen misst
und schon Wochen vor einem internen Kurzschluss
auf Schädigungen im Akku hinweisen soll. Und es
gibt auch noch viel weitere Forschung, auf die wir
hier leider nicht im Detail eingehen können.
#Werbung
Bevor wir zum Fazit des Videos kommen:
E-Autos brennen zwar seltener, aber ein erhöhtes
Risiko besteht dennoch beim Laden. Wer sein Auto
nämlich über die normale Haushalts-Steckdose lädt,
der riskiert, dass durch veraltete Kontaktstellen
ein zu hoher elektrischer Widerstand entsteht. Und
dieser kann dann einen Brand auslösen. Deswegen
empfehlen alle, von der Feuerwehr, über den ADAC
bis hin zu Versicherern eine gesicherte Wallbox.,
Und eine besonders sichere und
smarte Lösung bietet Zaptec an.
Die Zaptec Go Wallbox ist gerade mal so groß wie
ein iPad, liefert dafür aber bis zu 22 kW und
wurde in Norwegen schon zum Sicherheits-Testsieger
auserkoren. Aber auch hier in Deutschland wurde
Zaptec Go erfolgreich vom TÜV auf Herz und
Nieren geprüft. Außerdem ist sie echt schick
und lässt sich echt leicht installieren.
Ausschlaggebend für meine Empfehlung ist aber,
dass die Wallbox von Zaptec in Verbindung
mit Tibber genutzt werden kann.
Tibber ist ein besonders smarter Ökostromanbieter,
dem es gelungen ist, den echten Strompreis,
der gerade an der Strombörse gehandelt wird,
an seine Nutzer weiterzugeben. Das bedeutet,
dass ihr euer E-Auto in der Regel mittags
und nachts super günstig laden könnt - und
mit Tibbers Smart Charging Funktion geht das sogar
vollautomatisch, ohne lästiges Micromanagement.
Und weil die Zaptec Go Wallbox mit Tibber Hand in
Hand geht, bekommt ihr sie auch im Tibber-Store.
Das ist wichtig, denn mit unserem Code “WHATSON”
bekommt ihr bei eurer Tibber-Anmeldung direkt
einen 50€ Store-Gutschein. Das macht Zaptec und
Tibber nicht nur zu einer smarten und sicheren
Lösung, sondern auch zu einer kostengünstigen.
Und mit diesem Wallbox-Fazit kommen wir nun auch
zu unserem Video-Fazit …
#Werbung Ende
#Fazit
So. Was nehmen
wir mit? E-Autos sind sicher. Beim
Blick auf die Zahlen sieht man,
dass E-Autos deutlich seltener brennen als
Verbrenner. Die Brände werden natürlich zunehmen,
aber einfach weil mehr E-Autos
auf den Straßen unterwegs sind.
Und Feuerwehren können E-Autos löschen, aber
die Frage ist oft, ob es nicht vielleicht
sogar sinnvoller ist, ein Auto ausbrennen
zu lassen. Wir überlegen übrigens gerade,
ob wir ein extra Video mit dem Feuerwehrmann
machen, weil er uns wirklich viele spannende Dinge
erklärt hat. Wenn ihr euch das gerne angucken
würdet, dann schreibt uns das gerne mal in die
Kommentare! Ach ja, und die Recyclingbranche
hat zwar noch ein paar offene Fragen zu klären,
aber auch da ist klar, wo es hingeht.
Das nächste Mal, wenn jemand beim Familienessen
anfängt, über brennende E-Autos zu
reden, bist du jetzt vorbereitet,
schick ihnen gerne dieses Video hier. Bis dahin,
guten Appetit und bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.